this video is sponsored by Girl cafe gun
the world of entertainment is an
absolutely bizarre one but one we can't
seem to take our eyes off of we can
idolize celebrities obsess over them
that sometimes it may seem like they are
some unreachable objects that can be
sold objectified and commodified so much
so that there are some of us that can
forget that they are just like us people
but what is it like behind all the
lights and glamor how much of what was
shown is based on lies and deceits and
what is it like to be one of these
celebrities does your favorite girl
really love you
well of course it doesn't you delusional
[ __ ] or shinoko is the manga that
explores these exact topics now for the
longest time I was one of those anime
fans that would get confused whenever a
new show would be announced and all
these manga readers would Scurry out and
be hyped about it but now being in Japan
getting exposure to the hottest new
titles I think I finally found one
ashinoko is a series where it's only a
matter of time before this gets licensed
and it is too good to not get an anime
adaptation eventually and I'm just happy
to be on the other side of the fence for
once for that so I just wanted to talk
about this a bit today but before we get
on to this series I just wanted to talk
about today's sponsor Girl cafe gun let
me tell you about Girl cafe gun it's got
girls it's called guns and it also has a
cafe
probably Girl cafe gun is a new action
RPG that combines high intensity third
person shooter gameplay with live 2D
interactions and management systems that
all look absolutely great I was actually
really impressed with the gameplay which
resembles the old-school top-down bullet
Hells which not only tests your reflexes
and mechanics but you also need to
manage your team comps and strategies
going into different stages Pokemon guys
we all know the real reason we're here
you've also got all these amazing girls
you can collect with a diverse bonding
system to get closer to the girls you
like and increase your relationships
with them and don't forget you get to
run your own virtual Cafe with them as
well it's a game that combines many
different genres and systems but you
know what it's like they Cherry Picked
all the little things I look for and put
them into one game you'll be dodging
bullets one moment and then patting your
waifu's head the next so really what
more can you ask for if like me this
looks like everything you want in the
game then click the link in the
description to try it out today you can
also use the code on screen right now
for free gifts thank you again to Girl
cafe gun for sponsoring today's video
and with that said let's go back to
talking about oshinoko it's one of those
titles that is worth giving a chance
just because of the names behind it
coming from the same artist that did
scum's wish written by the mangaka of
kagia summer because while still writing
and drawing kagyasama doing a weekly
serialized manga which is famous for
pushing many artists to their limits AKA
akasaka was just like
let's start another one
but despite the names behind it you
wouldn't be able to get what this manga
is about just by reading the synopsis or
the beginning I mean this was my
experience reading chapter one Okay so
we've got some Idol story here that's
cool and um what the [ __ ] gynecologist
what the [ __ ] teen pregnancy what the
[ __ ] he's already dead what the [ __ ]
he's the baby now
what yeah you heard that right the main
characters an idol obsessed gynecologist
who finds out that his favorite Idol is
pregnant promises he's gonna deliver the
baby then gets [ __ ] murdered by one
of her obsessed fans and then he gets
reborn has her [ __ ] baby I say again
what the [ __ ] I thought I was getting
some Idol manga then by the end of
chapter one I had enough physical
Whiplash to give me neck problems but
then the babies have memories of their
past life and then they can talk and I'm
just like what the [ __ ] is this Michelle
could tensei gynecologist reincarnation
did I just stumble upon some [ __ ] Ida
Lisa guy but trust me when I say this
strange premise doesn't really have much
to do with what the series is actually
about well kinda it's hard to explain
there is a major subplot I don't want to
spoil but the premise basically just
gives this convoluted reason for I's son
Aqua to become an actor and following
his mother's footsteps and starting his
journey into the Twisted world of show
business it's an unfiltered look at the
Japanese entertainment industry from the
eyes of the people working behind it it
Raw it's real and oftentimes it can get
pretty dark resulting in what I think is
one of the most promising titles to be
released in recent years if anyone was a
big fan of act age and like me was
severely disappointed in what happened
then in many ways oshinoko is my
spiritual successor showing people in
the acting field breaking down the
talents and commitment it takes to be a
successful actor but unlike act age the
series isn't just limited to acting
Idols reality shows TV dramas stage
plays the series takes you on the
journey through the underbelly behind
the scenes of the Japanese entertainment
industry and shows you what it means to
be the people behind the camera up on
that stage with hundreds or thousands of
people cheering you on what it takes to
get there and the effect it can have on
any individual who finds themselves in
that position the manga doesn't pull any
punches when it comes to its depiction
of the modern entertainment landscape
not to say it's all doom and gloom I
mean come on it's coming from the same
author as kagio summer but it doesn't
shy away with just
showing things for what they are the
series literally starts off dismantling
the idle industry openly embracing the
entire industry as a facade a fake image
sold by how talented the Stars on stage
are at being Liars I hoshino's whole
existence is in a world of Lies her lies
to her audience is her form of love it
is a lie we buy into and not only does
the series straight up tell you that but
it can celebrate it as well no matter
what sector of entertainment it explores
it never stops reminding you that show
business is a show business everything
is deception Everything is marketable
Everything can become a commodity but
underneath the surface the real strength
in the series is AKA akasaka's ability
to write sympathetic characters behind
the fame and glamor are real people
people that have to live in this world
of deception people who have to deal
with the pressures of being constantly
judged not only By Their audience but
the industry they work in what I love is
that aside from maybe the main character
how human everyone feels everyone has
all these little insecurities and
anxieties that you can relate to and
these only gets enhanced by working in
the entertainment industry to say that
entering the Cutthroat world of Show
Business won't be detrimental to your
mental health is a bit like saying
entering the JoJo fandom will leave you
with an unsucked dick
[Music]
okay
and the manga doesn't pull any punches
when exploring the effects of this
industry on the talent's mental health
it humanizes these inhuman Idols it
makes you see the Twisted World they
have to live in and one thing that
impressed me the most was that it did it
in a way that's all the more relevant
right now traditional celebrity culture
has thankfully been on the decline in
recent years we can all see that they
are all also human some of them have
flaws and a lot of them are very very
out of touch with the current times and
we can all agree that paparazzis are
below dung beetles in the social
hierarchy all right maybe that was a bit
harsh
dung beets are actually good for the
environment but then the place that has
been the rise of the social media
celebrity before celebrity figures might
have felt like they were up on this
pedestal Untouchable and unreachable but
now some of the most influential figures
have never been more relatable more
seemingly in reach and thankfully the
author seems to be very in touch with
the modern landscape because social
media plays a massive part in many of
these stories I was pleasantly surprised
when I saw stories about people trying
to become successful YouTubers and
Instagrams and tick tocks because I was
like yeah yeah now you're coming in my
neck of the woods it was surreal seeing
a manga that was basically centered
around my career and Industry and coming
from the inside seeing these stories
based around influences and their
culture
he does a [ __ ] great job all right
I'm about to go in a tangent that
doesn't seem like he has anything to do
with anything but trust me I do have a
point and it does relate back to this
[ __ ] manga alright here's a little
secret I really hope won't come back to
bite me in the ass in the future by
admitting I often wonder how I would
handle
getting canceled okay this is not to
[ __ ] say that I sit in front of a
mirror rehearsing how to say I've made a
severe and continuous lapse in my
judgment nor do I think there's anything
I've done which I'm scared is going to
get exposed and I'm gonna have to
apologize about but as a YouTuber whose
career is tied to my online presence and
image cancel culture and how to properly
manage that has become a massive factor
in my job it can be something that ends
careers or it can be something that you
brush off and move on from but
regardless no one is immune to its
effect no matter how much you think
someone is uncancelable let's talk about
apology videos for example if you think
about it apology video should be a
simple Affair someone does something
wrong so they apologize and then people
forgive them or they don't but nowadays
people getting canceled and creative
apologies have become so commonplace
that it's almost become a cliche good
apologies bad apologies over time we've
been exposed to the entire [ __ ]
Spectrum so much so that you could even
say that there's even a [ __ ] meta for
YouTuber apology videos that we can
bring Down parody and sometimes even
Rank and that's because apology videos
aren't about being sorry
it's about winning back public favor
it's PR even if the person is actually
sorry like if I had to make an apology
video regardless of if I was being
genuine or not it's actually irrelevant
because all that's important is about
making you believe that I'm being
genuine and unfortunately being genuine
and trying to convince a mass audience
that you are being genuine are two
entirely different things now this may
seem like a strange tangent to go on
that may look like I have a weird
Obsession about the thought of getting
canceled but that's because I was
astonished when I saw ocean okor dealing
with this exact topic not only does it
portray what happens when you're just
flooded with hate comments that puts you
in this self-destructive Loop you can't
escape from that gives you this
suffocating feeling which I can never
truly describe in words to someone who
hasn't been in that same position but it
also addresses how fickle public opinion
can be and how easily it can Sway and
even the tactics and strategies you can
use to sway it to your side and game the
system they have a full-on Death Note
style breakdown of the mechanics of
getting canceled and how to uncancel
yourself and I was absolutely amazed
reading this because some of this stuff
was exactly the same stuff I've thought
about because that's just what the
ecosystem has become so the biggest
compliment I can give is that from
someone working on the other side of the
industry is that oshinokor was pretty
spot on with its portrayal it managed to
make a super compelling story arc out of
it and made me feel not like a
psychopath for thinking this deeply
about getting canceled I've made a
severe this is just one of the story
arcs that the manga has dealt with in
the many facets of Japanese
entertainment and regardless of if I've
been as familiar with them as this
example so far they've all been as
equally compelling and as far as I can
tell as equally well researched right
now the there are only five volumes out
in Japan so it's still very early days
but I only see this growing in strengths
there are so many facets it still could
explore I mean I honestly wouldn't be
surprised if there was an arc about
YouTubers in the future with how much
AKA akasaka is in touch with the modern
entertainment landscape also for the
record kaneo's best girl I've claimed
her back off weebs keep an eye out for
this title in the future because if I
was a betting man this is getting an
anime adaptation one day and yeah that's
pretty much all I wanted to say this is
a great manga so let's just go straight
to the outro thank you again to Girl
cafe gun for sponsoring me today as you
can see I am back in Japan this video
was not pre-recorded at all I literally
started working the moment I landed you
know what I'm just happy to be doing
more manga videos so I'll probably do
more in the future say hello to the
manga Zone also not taking a break from
doing things after I've landed but I'm
gonna be moving next month I'm planning
to change a lot with my studio upgrading
my desk and possibly doing a new
background so look forward to that so
yeah that is my month of October sorted
and I'll hopefully have time to make
videos in between all that until then
though I'm happy to be back I've been
gig up and I'll see you all next time
bye